♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, DEVIN NUNES PREPARING
EIGHT CRIMINAL REFERRALS FOR THE
ETERNAL GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
OVER ALLEGED MISCONDUCT OR THE
TRUMP/RUSH INVESTIGATION.
ALSO, JUST BREAKING OUT, DEVIN
NUNES HAS FILED $150 MILLION
LAWSUIT AGAINST McCLATCHY NEWS
AND ALLEGING CONSPIRACY TO
DERAIL THE CLINTON/RUSSIA
PROBES.
CONGRESSMAN JOINS US WITH THE
VERY LATEST.
LET'S START WITH YOUR LAWSUIT.
AND WHAT IS IT McCLATCHY
MICHAEL -- SAID MICHAEL WAS A
PRAGUE?
>> I KNEW THE SON OF A GREAT
ATHLETE, HIS SON WAS IN
LOS ANGELES WITH HIS SON.
LET'S JUST SAY SHOWING UP HIS
SON'S GREAT TALENT.
HE NEVER WAS IN PRAGUE.
AND THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON STUPID.
>> Devin: THEY DID THAT TWICE,
SHONE SO DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
STORIES.
A COUPLE OF REPORTERS THE
BIGGEST PERPETUATORS OF THE
RUSSIA HOAX.
DON'T FORGET, THEY ALSO TARGETED
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
AND LAWYER MITCHELL.
SO THIS WAS ALL DONE IN CONCERT
WHILE SLANDERING AND ATTACKING
THE REPUBLICANS IN DEFAMING THE
REPUBLICANS.
THE WHOLE TIME GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM SOMEONE.
SO PART OF THE LAWSUIT, NOT ONLY
THAT THEY NEED TO RETRACT
EVERYTHING THEY DID AGAINST ME,
BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO COME CLEAN
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
RETRACT ALL OF THE FAKE NEWS
STORIES.
SO THIS IS PART OF THE BROADER
CLEANUP.
REMEMBER, A FEW WEEKS AGO I
FILED AGAINST TWITTER.
THEY THEY ARE SINTERING
CONSERVATIVES.
McCLATCHY IS THE WORST
OFFENDER OF THIS.
COMING AFTER THE REST OF THEM.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE JUST
BEGINNING TO WAKE UP NOW THAT
I'M SERIOUS AND I'M COMING TO
CLEAN UP ALL OF THE MESS.
IF YOU ARE OUT THERE AND YOU
LIED IN YOU DEFAMED, WE ARE
GOING TO COME AFTER YOU.
>> Sean: I WOULD ADD TO THE
LIST THE COWARDLY SHIFT.
I WILL COME TO AN HOUR ON THE
SHOW AND I HAVE A DOSSIER --
>> Devin: I CAN'T SUE HIM.
I OFFERED HIM THREE HOURS ON
RADIO AND ONE HOUR HERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY HE DOESN'T
TAKE IT UP.
>> Devin: I GUESS HE'S AFRAID.
>> Sean: I GOT A TAPE OF HIM
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS,
SOMEONE THAT NEEDS TO BE A
RUSSIAN COMPROMISING MATERIALS
UP NAKED PICTURES OF TRUMP.
HE WAS HYPERVENTILATING ON THE
PHONE AND IT WAS A HOAX.
>> Devin: DON'T FORGET EVEN
AFTER THAT COME WITH THE STAFF
TO FOLLOW DEPTHS THE MEDIA
IGNORED AND THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THEY IGNORED.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN THIS, FAKE NEWS
STORIES THAT WERE SLANDEROUS
THAT HAVE GOT TO BE WIPED AWAY
AND CLEANED OFF OF THE INTERNET.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY WOULD
TAKE THESE STORIES AND IGNORE
THEM LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU HAD
STAFFERS HERE WHO WERE
ATTEMPTING TO COLLUDE WITH
RUSSIANS, DEMOCRATIC STAFFERS
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIANS TRYING
TO GET INFORMATION ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT REALLY HAPPENED, AND
LARGELY UNREPORTED EXCEPT BY A
FEW CONSERVATIVE MEDIA.
>> Sean: WE HAVE THE HILLARY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
PAID FOR THE INFLUENCE OF THE
ELECTION.
NOW, WE'VE GOT EVIDENCE.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ON THEM WITH
EVIDENCE AND OBTAINED AND THEY
FIRED HIM.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME BUT I
WANT TO GET TO THE CRIMINAL
REFERRAL ISSUE.
I KNOW YOU BEGAN WITH EIGHT, BUT
THERE MIGHT BE MORE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US, AND HOW
SOON?
>> Devin: SIMPLY PUT FIVE
STRAIGHTFORWARD, FIVE ON LEAKING
TO CONGRESS, FIVE SPECIFIC
NAMES.
THERE ARE THREE, ONE IS A GLOBAL
LEAK REFERRAL.
SO REMEMBER, THERE HAS BEEN --
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT GENERAL
PLAN AND THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT'S BEEN
INVESTIGATED BUT THERE'S A
DOZEN OTHERS.
SO REFERRING ALL OF THOSE TO
MAKE SURE THEY GET THE PROPER
SUNLIGHT PUT ON THEM AND
TRANSPARENCY SO THEY CAN BE
FOLLOWED UP ON.
THE OTHER TWO I THINK MORE
DIFFICULT THAT INVOLVE
CONSPIRACY.
I THINK THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE THAT WANTED TO BE THE
NEXT WATERGATE WITH FBI AND DOJ
AND THEY WERE LEAKING AND PROUD
TO DO IT.
THEY WERE ALL CONSPIRING
TOGETHER AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR.
>> Sean: IF WE DON'T HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS ABUSE TO
POWER, THIS CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS TO FIRST
INFLUENCE AND HELP ONE CANDIDATE
OVER ANOTHER AND THEN,